can't because we're at the bottom we're
at the bottom of the food chain yeah
although that article came out saying
that asians were with what are with
whites now we're basically
that's we're widely adjacent bro we
should have a party
we've been waiting it's you you've been
waiting to be invited
for [ __ ] a thousand years not me and
gilbert asians though it's just you asia
i know that already that's obviously on
the phone
he's okay with that yeah i'm okay with
that but um thank you so thank you so
much for inviting chinese japanese and
koreans to your to your group there we
go you're very welcome appreciate it and
maybe um
a thousand years down the road i might
be able to throw in a word for these
guys
you know once i'm in there and we're
like i'm doing the country club thing
with you guys and drinking the um i can
promise you it's not a korean who is
going to speak on behalf of a filipino
i'm not going to speak for filipinos i'm
going to get you two guys into a club
man just me and gilbert yeah so look at
us like mine but everyone's gonna be
like you got you brought those from
that's obvious
that's obvious i don't want to be looked
at like that and also you're going to
have jobs when you're in the group how
about how are we elitist no you're not
actually a part of it but you're going
to get in by working for me so that's my
issue catering their parties yeah that's
right we're just giving champagne to
people anyway hearing their white
adjacent so thank you so much white
people for inviting asians into your
club we've been waiting for a long time
appreciation i want to say something go
ahead congrats
thank you
thank you what does it feel like up
there oh my god it feels
so good friends take notes guild okay
okay so the other day i was in irvine
tell us papa i will and i looked at a
white person in the eyes yeah right and
i don't know if you guys know this but
this is something but white people can
only look at immigrants in the eyes for
four to five seconds really yeah if you
look at any movie
you look at sydney point and tony curtis
in that one movie where they were
escaping from the train
where they were in prison i mean but
they were a train train's fine well they
did escape from a train yeah they want
to train but they were tied together
right and those two only looked at each
other in the eyes for five seconds
that's the mess i heard about i i assume
but my point is is that but now i was in
irvine and a lady looked in my eyes for
eight seconds
and i was just like i almost melted
inside my heart yeah yeah and then all
of a sudden and then i went to the
grocery store and i got
coffee's cheaper
coffee's cheaper baseball gloves cheaper
baseball balls dude i went you know i've
never bought a baseball club before were
you at exactly i went to sam goodies man
yeah they did the asian text has been
removed right so i went to that good egg
why did jason and i went to the white
guy i go hey can i how much does this
goggle club basic glove yeah yeah
he's like
get out of my store you could say that
but he gave me the glove winked chin got
it at the store and i got it for free
so thank you so much you get a lot of
perks when you're
you know i'm sorry i know i'm i'm
honestly like kind of jealous yeah man
yeah
and you get extra stuff different stuff
at restaurants
like
you get to salt your own food this time
no you get something but you can get
stuff like
like if you're at like um let's say
you're a pizza hut
and you have a white waiter and you know
this and you white people never talked
about this
the thing and you go
can i get caviar
they'll get it for you at a pizza spot
yeah
so if i go to cp or he goes to cpk he
can get a barbecue pizza and say i'd
like a side of caviar
or give you a barbecue oh yeah barbecue
pizza or get a pizza that that place
doesn't even have like a deep dish
they'll thicken the crust they'll
thicken the crust they do extra [ __ ] you
know this man tell them
oh yeah you don't know the off menu
yes thank you tell them it's all the
rage in small town michigan yeah sounds
good with that anywho i want to tell
everyone at irvine thank you for coming
out what a great show i it was a bobby
lee and friends show uh